[Music]
[Applause]
I spent the first nine years of my
career at Google which was probably
about eight and a half years longer than
I thought I was gonna stay there after
my first week but I got a lot out of it
this talk is probably a lot closer to
the work I was doing at Google then the
work I'm doing now which is why I
mentioned the Google thing in the first
place I'm built big distributed systems
at Google and now I'm working on big
psychosocial systems that this startup
called matter not to be confused with
the medium magazine called matter or the
other startup called matter that I'm
incredibly irritated about but but we're
we're building a something that I think
is pretty interesting and special for
that's that's sort of designed to be an
antidote to social media which is a
plague okay so anyway this is going to
be a short talk because that's that's
how it is I'm going to try really hard
not to rehash what's in some really
excellent talks that you can read slides
for online Rob Pike has given incredible
talks on concurrency I will not be
trying to cover that material I will try
to get a couple of nuggets through
hopefully that are interesting to people
and something that you enjoy thinking
about and maybe our novel that's really
what I'm aiming to do and if again
anyone wants to talk about the stuff
send me an email or talk to me
afterwards and I'll try to stay for a
while I love talking to people all right
so healthy distributed systems I I think
it would be good to start by talking
about just my kind of reflections having
spent a long time at Google working with
distributed systems what I really like
to see in them the first thing is I like
the high order bits to be right I don't
really care that much about they're like
incredible details especially for things
like throughput like if you if you spend
nine months like tuning your throughput
into oblivion it's likely that by the
time you're done like Hardware will have
and faster than whatever improvement you
made in that like nine months you know
it's just I think it's really smart to
think about the the high-order bits of
performance definitely want to be with
an order of magnitude of what's you know
what should be possible by the raw
numbers I also think it's important to
get the shape of the system right like I
think it's incredibly important to be
able to build systems out of small
composable pieces and not these like
monolithic things go does great on both
of these fronts especially and ladder I
think and go it feels somehow very like
stress-free to me to like to build a new
process and go that has its own main
line that doesn't see out at all whereas
my brief and traumatic experience its
rails was something where I felt like it
was actually kind of a big deal to make
another rails application and having
many of them going concurrently I know
that maybe I there's not a great reason
for it but for some reason just felt all
wrong with go it doesn't I think I was
saying to do with just the philosophy of
the system and everything seems pretty
simple the standard library is readable
and so on and so forth I think that
out-of-the-box performance and go is
also a huge breath of fresh air if
you're coming from node or rails or
Python or something like that it still
leaves something to be desired and I'll
talk about that later and I think it
does come into play with particularly
with large fan-out systems but in
general I'm really pleased with the
performance so I think it's also really
important in the distributed system and
I'll talk about this a little bit more
if it's big enough you're going to have
enough people working on it that you
didn't write all the code and so you
need to be able to you know hopefully
edit multiple layers of the stack and I
think it's equally really important to
to be able to do that without bothering
other teams like if you want to send
them a small review that touches some of
their code and your team in your company
you should be able to do that
confidently and I think that static
typing and what go has done here is
invaluable this is not news I think and
this is why I think a lot of people feel
I feel I had to do a huge refactor last
summer and we made some significant
changes to our product which is all the
backend it's written and go and it was
just it was it was actually like almost
joyful to just like change a bunch of
types and fix and pile errors and that
was done it was kind of working it was
really remarkable and I think that's a
testament to to to go that that was a
fairly pleasant process
I'll times of course are also a huge
improvement over some other statically
typed languages but again this is
nothing new and I'm not going to dwell
on stuff that's been well well covered
already another thing I like about go-go
routines make it really beautiful
actually to handle things like flow
control even like multi-tiered flow
control and pushing back instead of just
like running out of memory and crashing
is also really elegant and go and is
something that I was talking to someone
just before the talk about how they were
able to replace like three levels of
complexity with a single go service that
replaced I think it was like replacing
some sort of nginx thing and another
load balancer and
service all just got replaced by one one
you know one go binary that had no
trouble with performance and when it's
running out of resources just five
hundreds instead of crashes which is
what you want so I and I'll share these
slides if anyone cares but I link to a
deck where people describe this piece of
it in more detail now we're getting the
areas where I think go is not doing
quite as well the bug ability I'll talk
a lot more about later in this talk but
I think it's a actually an area of
significant weakness for go especially
when you're talking about really big
systems and I'll talk more about that
later and this has nothing to do with go
but I just I'm kind of feel like as long
as I have opportunity to talk to people
I want to reiterate how important I
think it is for inter-process
communication to be done in a way that's
self documenting and that's sort of code
for saying I think using protobufs or
thrift or something like that or Avro
whatever is really important I think
JSON makes sense when you need to build
an API for people outside of your
company and you want to make sure that
they can get started quickly with your
product but I think that building JSON
API is or similar things like that that
that require kind of code comments a
document how they work is sort of a bad
idea in the long term I think that
maintenance issues there are significant
I think also that the serialization
deserialization and a high throughput
service can become significant and and
I'm a really firm believer and trying to
be a little bit more formal about it and
somehow this makes me feel like there's
an analogy between JSON and JavaScript
and like protobufs or thrift and go and
essentially have a little bit more
typing but actually
I think saves you time in the long run
in terms of sort of maintenance
headaches and and compatibility issues
all right so this is a slide that I
stole pretty shamelessly
from a deck that Jeff Dean and Luis
Barroso presented from at Berkeley it's
a really great presentation it goes into
a lot more detail about about kind of
performance tricks and distributed
systems and trade Austrian throughput
and latency that are made at Google and
I was actually surprised that they
published it I thought it revealed a
bunch of kind of heuristic things that
that I would I didn't think they would
talk about publicly so it's a great
presentation I really just wanted to
steal this I didn't feel like trying to
do this in Google presentations so
basically this is just a diagram of what
I think is a pretty typical serving
system you have a query coming into some
kind of top-level front end and in this
situation the front end you know has
some ad system it sends things off to
you and also a sense to what Google
calls the super route which is just this
this kind of like it's this process that
takes all the different things that can
be combined into Google search results
and merges them and ranks them and then
each one of these things is like a
multi-tiered sharded clone system and I
I can say I think without revealing
anything too surprising that like a
cache miss at Google Google search will
often hit like thousands or even tens of
thousands of processes before it gets
back to the user within you know
whatever a fraction of a second that
takes and so this is a really highly
tuned system and they're very very
sensitive to to latency the nodes here I
think it's worth saying that these
aren't replicas these are different
shards so you have a some corpus that's
too large to fit on one machine so you
split it into pieces each one of these
pieces is also replicated for load
balancing and that's not pictured here I
talked about this already I think it's
also important to say that when when you
see companies growing and of course
Google's larger than most the companies
that we work at but even a medium-sized
company I think you start seeing this
thing when you get about a hundred
people or so where the systems start to
be complicated enough that you don't
know how they work like you can't know
how they all work no one at the company
knows how everything works and you have
these communication issues that come
into
as well and this is again an area where
I think oh it really shines compared to
something like rails I mean I think part
of the reason that Twitter had trouble
really making significant product
changes for several years was because
they were trying to get themselves out
of that mode where they got themselves
with rails into into a scheme where it
was easier to make changes confidently
and I mean that's just my opinion from
talking with people I know who worked
there but but I I do think that it's a
really significant cost like the
communication cost of code is a huge
deal and when you start scaling out is
maybe even a bigger deal than the cost
of implementing things like being able
to understand things and change things
quickly I think is really important and
go I think is is a great step from a lot
of the other kind of popular languages
people are using to build stuff quickly
these days
I'm going to move into kind of talking
about latency which will be the next
section of this talk and and I'll get a
little bit more detailed now I should
have said this earlier but if people
have any questions or if I'm going to
quickly just please interrupt me or
raise your hand it welcome that I did
actually draw this myself unlike that
chart I stole earlier this is you know a
pretty straightforward chart like a
latency distribution I see a lot of
things like I know that New Relic
recently introduced 95th percentile
latency which I'm glad they've done that
but I think it's be suspicious of people
who talked about average latency it's
really important if you're talking about
a system that other things depend on or
if it shorted out this red area is what
you really care about and even if you
have a really beautiful like tight
little distribution and close to low
latency requests so you have most of the
requests are being serviced very quickly
if you have bumps over here this is a
big deal and this is an area where I
think go right now actually has some
problems I also think it's an area where
go is naturally going to improve
especially past 1.5 I think less reading
their their documentation but what
they're planning on doing I have some
high hopes for it but but the key
observation is that if you have a
service that has one component in it
this is actually not a big deal it's
like if 1% of your requests take you
know while they longer than everything
else they take orders of magnitude
longer than then the 99% of requests
that's ok if there's only one of those
but
it's just the kind of birthday paradox
thing as you add machines into that
picture if there are a hundred processes
in your system and 1% them are really
slow 63% of your requests are going to
hit one of those machines and so things
like garbage collection hiccups can
become a really big deal if you have to
spread them out across you know
distributed systems with lots of
components and if you're not willing to
just time out and you have to return the
results in that process it's even more
of an issue I also I also do this this
is my crowning achievement this
presentation it's all downhill from here
in terms of graphics I hope this makes
sense this is um I'm going to talk a
little bit about distributed tracing in
a bit and this is how dapper which is
Google's distributed tracing system and
how Zipkin which is the one that Twitter
open-source recently this is roughly how
they visualize these things so you
should see this this thing at the top
this bar is one request like let's say
it's one user facing requests and each
of these things that it directly calls
into our systems it depends on and makes
let's say it's making our pcs of these
systems and as we're flowing across you
can see you know time is obviously
extending and the key observation here
is that this is a very very typical
shape for a distributed trace at least
in my experience of looking at them and
in common distributed systems you have
some fan-out where you have these three
backends you know you process them
mostly in parallel maybe there's a
little bit of latency between these
various requests going out but this top
request let's imagine that it basically
it makes these three it makes these
three requests in a pretty short order
and now it's just waiting until they all
come back before it can make this final
request so perhaps like this is an
insert into a cache service or Redis or
something like that so most the bulk of
the requests your process is sitting
there not doing anything this top-level
process waiting for its backends and
this back ends return in sort of similar
fashion they have their own backends and
they return as soon as they're all done
but you have this one guy here let's say
that this one was you know what was
having a queueing issue or it was having
a hiccup from garbage collection this
single request
you know slows things down substantially
because I couldn't fit it there's only
you know five of these but it really is
not uncommon for this to be more like
twenty or fifty or a hundred in some
cases and that can become a really big
problem so these are the things that end
up slowing stuff down we did an analysis
while I was at Google using some of the
dapper data across the entire company
and looked for critical paths on on web
search so the critical path of course is
just to refresh people's memory it's
just every process that was actually
holding up the main request so you can
see that these guys aren't you know like
they finished in time and there was
loads of time before this guy finished
so it's not an issue so the critical
path is something that we're incredibly
interested in and ultimately that's what
you need to optimize if you want the end
user query to come back quickly and and
what you end up seeing almost invariably
is that slow requests are due to one or
maybe two requests like underneath that
the top-level thing that we're trying to
satisfy that took too long or took way
longer than their peers and this is what
latency and that like latency analysis
in distributed systems ends up being
focused on finding and eliminating these
it's not really on making this any
faster
if this is your these guys are your a
problem you're in really good shape its
these ones that you have to worry about
does that make sense okay okay so back
to go so garbage collection is something
I think we're a little nervous but I
talked about a bunch of things about go
that I think are great I'm not dwelling
on those because I think that the go
team has done a really good job
explaining what's so great about Co but
there are areas that I think do you
require a little bit more attention I
have to admit that my use of go and
production is has been at post Google
and I haven't really been able to push
it as hard as we push things at Google
I've never run into an issue with GC
that felt material like it you know
we've seen it we've seen little blips
but it's not a huge thing
I'm positive if we end up with systems
that had hundreds of components that it
would definitely be a thing and it may
be not a big thing that would be a thing
and I'm pretty distressed by the current
implementation for the GC and go I'm
also pretty encouraged by what they're
planning to do about it I think that
their focus is just right they've had to
choose a heuristic I mean GC is a very
difficult thing to do either you do what
Java does and you have some like insane
number of parameters you exposed to
people and it becomes the sort of
configuration nightmare
or you just sort of take a guess at what
an appropriate configuration is for
people and I think they're kind of
airing on that side of the spectrum
right now which I'm actually happy about
because that job I think makes me
totally crazy but I I am a little bit
concerned that like if anyone's trying
to build something that's super
real-time they're gonna run two issues
their plan of record is and if anyone
has better information please correct me
but my understanding is that their plan
is to get to a point with go on five or
even with go on four aware to stop the
world garbage collection will only
happen for ten milliseconds at a time
out of every 50 millisecond block so
basically it will stop the world take
ten milliseconds do as much as it can if
it's done great if it's not done spend
the next 40 milliseconds probably you
know doing concurrent garbage collection
in a less efficient way at the expense
of throughput but giving latency a break
and I think their assumption is that ten
milliseconds is never gonna kind of
break the bank for anybody in terms of
latency certainly nothing like some of
these like kind of nightmare scenarios
where your process stops for five
seconds while while the garbage
collector goes and does its thing so I
am hopeful about that the other good
news about this I guess is that even if
this is an issue it's not impossible to
program around this you can you can make
multiple requests to clones and just
cancel the one that comes back second or
you can build your own allocator
basically with free pools
which is really agonizing but definitely
an option and and something that people
can pursue and and I am optimistic about
where this is going although I don't
think it's quite there yet and if I was
in charge of a company that was you know
building some really high high
throughput low latency system I would be
a little nervous about this right now so
yeah sometimes there are thousands of
prostitutes involved in a request or
even hundreds it becomes an issue and I
think another thing that people don't
talk enough about with distributed
systems but I think invariably becomes
an issue once the system's become
sufficiently complicated is that you you
cannot understand what's happening in
them just by looking at logs and
certainly by looking at the code like
you'll have a request that takes too
long or you'll see some kind of strange
error and there's almost no way to
figure out what happened I think the the
reason why that becomes a problem is
that vanilla logging where you're just
logging to a local disk or
maybe you're lugging local disk and then
and then you know using paper trail or
log li or something like that to
aggregate the logs is not that effective
in highly concurrent systems because
either you do the thing where you only
log significant surprising events like
errors which is fine but then like
everyday requests you have no
information or you do find grain logging
per request and you end up in a
situation where either log and becomes
like materially expensive and or you
have so much interference if you're
handling it in go which which does
concurrent processing really you know
beautifully and easily if you're
processing 100 requests concurrently and
they're all logging concurrently if
you're looking at that log file it's
kind of madness to try to understand
what's actually happening because of all
the interference from different from
different governs or different
subroutines of things does that make
sense I think so it gets even worse if
you then make this instead of just
debugging a concurrent system on one
machine or in one process you're now T
bugging a concurrent system across many
machines and this is the situation that
you find yourself in if you're building
a high throughput low latency system you
end up in it's just it's foolish I think
to try and actually figure out what
happened if you have a hundred processes
that are all doing concurrent work and
you're trying to figure out why one
request went awry you're in big trouble
and so this is why distributed tracing
systems become an issue once companies
get to a certain scale and once products
get to a certain scale is that you need
to have some way of figuring out on a
per request basis not just for one
process but across processes what
happened you just want to know like you
want to have a basic log of just the
usual stuff you would log to like a you
know a v1 type fine log and you also
want to know basic timing information
when did a request come in when did it
go out when did it finish that sort of
stuff and I think that this is an area
and this is the nugget that I'm hoping
to convey tonight that I think go has a
significant problem I actually don't
know how to do this and go and if anyone
does I'd love to talk to you afterwards
I think it's a pretty interesting thing
so a distributed trace is a log of
concurrent activities so things that are
happening at the same time and I think
people who've used go if I read all the
concurrency versus parallelism stuff in
this case they're probably concurrent
and parallel if they're happening in
multiple processes it doesn't matter the
point is that they're just happening
and that you're also integrating them
from many places and that's the
distributed nature in order to do this
well leaves based on my experience
working on dapper and from what I've you
know what I've learned in my own career
anyway is that you need to have control
over the wire protocol that's no problem
for go and you need to have no code from
print and vanila function calls so if I
call a function it's not reasonable to
ask a developer to instrument every
single function call in our application
just so distributed tracing works it's
one of those things that you don't want
to care about at all until you need it
and then you want just to work and if it
requires a huge amount of developer
overhead it's not going to happen
especially across teams and across SDKs
and across API s and stuff like that
it's not going to happen so it needs to
work transparently across function calls
and also needs some way of integrating
with with execution queues so they kind
of you know the kind of runnable stuff
in java and c and c++ i don't know if
there's as much of a convention at
google we had things we had this call
back enclosure system but but I think
you're all familiar with the pattern you
have and you have some sort of queue you
put a synchronous work into the queue
that's another area where distributed
tracing needs to be pretty seamless you
want to make sure that when someone prod
if you put something into queue and then
it goes through the queue and it comes
out you need to make sure that the trace
knows that's still part of the same
that's still part of the same logical
request so you need to be able to
instrument that these are the three
things that are really important if you
can do these three things the rest of
it's really not that hard the rest is
just like building a pretty
straightforward collection system and
building a GUI around it but these these
three things are not not to be
negotiated around really so what this
boils down to is custom code and RPC
systems you rely heavily on thread-local
variables to avoid instrumentation you
sorry I avoid additional code overhead
in function calls and then you need some
kind of special runnable implementation
and you know i'm using the java
terminology here but it you know
whatever the work item you put into your
queue you need some way of instrumenting
that so that you can find out when it
starts running later and and have your
own tracing code called into play these
the first ones fine the last two are a
huge problem and go especially the
thread locals
so and go as it stands now the only way
I can imagine this working is they added
something that is thread locals or is
akin to thread locals so going back to
you know going back to this slide or
something like this if if you know in
the super ooh I want to call upon client
libraries that talk to that in this in
this diagram images and local news and
web and stuff like that I didn't write
those client libraries when I call them
it's not reasonable for me to assume
that they have added something for like
put in your trace context here you want
that just to happen automatically and
then go there's they seem pretty dead
set about keeping go routines super
super lightweight which means they seem
pretty dead sad about not adding thread
local stuff but then again I don't I
don't know how you would do bugs systems
of this scale or even an order of
magnitude simpler than this scale
without something that allows you to
connect the dots across processes and
again I think that this is something
that that go has some real work to
handle it some real work to do and then
similarly if if you have a channel which
is I think a beautiful concept and go
and really well implemented since
they've put that into the language
itself that is the execution queue of
choice and go and anyone who wants to
build a queueing system hopefully is
going to use channels to do it and I
think that this is another issue where
you can't just insert things into a
channel and expect it to do the right
stuff with tracing to do this right I I
didn't think I had time to really go
into what I think the proposal would be
but you need different parameters when
you create a channel somehow you need to
have some way to parameterize it to say
I want you to keep track of thread
locals or tracing information or give me
a chance to have a call back before
something isn't cued into a channel and
when it's when it's DQ'd from a channel
and i you know i am amused sometimes by
the go team I really I kind of like them
personally I know some of them from
Google but but they're they're very
principled about what they're trying to
do this to me sounds like the kind of
thing they would hate like it just
sounds like be kind of they would never
do and and I'm wondering if they
eventually will or if this is just going
to be this gap but right now if you
build a go process and it's in the
middle of the system and it's not at the
lowest level I I don't know how you can
figure out how the stuff that's coming
it's connected to stuff coming out in a
generalized way that would work across
across api's so yeah I guess I think I'm
maybe I hope I didn't go too fast am I
about right
I'm about right that's wonderful
so I think that go is pretty well
positioned to address almost everything
about distributed systems that I care
about I love the language I plan to use
it for everything until something better
comes out and I think the latency issue
is presently maybe a problem I think by
the end of next year I can't imagine
it's going to be a serious issue if they
do what they're saying they're going to
do right now I think it might be
slightly a problem and then I do have
the significant I have the significant
agreements about debugging my hope is
that eventually it really will be a
problem and that they'll fix it until
then I'm concerned about this and I
think this actually will be kind of a
blocker for a certain type of analysis
that is actually really essential once
you get to a certain scale but but until
then I I'm excited to use go and and I
really enjoy it so I think that's pretty
much the end of my slides I'm happy to
take questions at this point about any
of this or something else or or anything
or anything people want to ask great all
of you here for two hours
I'll tell great
yeah that's an interesting idea did
people hear the suggestion in the back
so the suggestion was to use a tool that
structurally is similar to go cover and
now it runs over your you know your the
binary are trying to build and inserts
instrumentation like the instrumentation
I'm talking about where it's needed I
think that's a really interesting idea I
think in a situation where you could
actually get pretty much everything done
automatically I think that would work in
practice to make the distributed tracing
function correctly you always end up
needing a certain amount of hand tuning
to you know like there will be some
situation where it shouldn't be traced
and it was traced like a situation we
have at Google sometimes is that a
request would come in at the very first
request would come in in a process and
while it was handling it a bunch of
lazily created structures would be would
be created and those things would make
millions of our pcs over their lifetime
they'd all be considered part of that
initial trace so you like you'll have to
do things real cut stuff out of the
trace and that sort of thing I think
would be it would be kind of odd to have
those api's in place but but also
require this separate build process but
I think it's an interesting idea and I
think could definitely help with a lot
of it it basically is like I think
that's akin to saying we have it's
almost like having a compiler flag it's
almost like you know when you compile
this I won't be something else another
thing I should have said about
distributed tracing is that it needs to
be running all the time in production
it's not something that you turn on for
your binary you push a debug binary to
production it needs to work all the time
and have no overhead that's perceptible
and and I think that could you know that
could cause people to forget about this
or something you want ideally it's
something that people don't need to
remember I could imagine a company
policy where you say you have to compile
everything here like this but ideally
it's something that's just that's just
on I think yeah but that's a good that's
a good suggestion
that's a great question so the question
was do do you trace everything that
comes in or do you sample some and so
the answer is sort of a little of both
you um you sample everything and you key
so basically I didn't have time to go
into a detailed description of how it
works but the summary is that every time
a new request is starting at the top of
the tree you basically pick a random
64-bit number and call that the ID for
the trace and then as the request
propagates across the distributed system
you pass the idea along with it and you
log stuff locally without not over the
network and certainly not as part of the
response but you log things locally
attach the ID if it's been traced you
always pass the IDS around so you do
that no matter what but you only do the
logging if a coin has been flipped and
you've decided this trace it's going to
be sampled and so one of the big
problems is how do you want to weight
that coin do you want to weigh two
equally just do it uniformly at Google
the default is 1 in every 1,024 requests
is is traced by default but then for
lower lower throughput systems they'll
bump it up to 1 for 1 or 1 for 16 or
whatever
in some situations you'll want to be
smarter about it and say oh this request
is going to be interesting because it
has a certain pattern match to it and so
I'm going to turn on tracing after the
fact and you can do that as well but but
but you you trace everything we only log
a fraction of it because the expensive
part is really that logging in the i/o
you have to handle off with logging is
the expensive part it's a great question
hello see the chart earlier on that was
something I personally felt pain that
the latency one in the critical path so
it's great to see this what I want to
know is how have you my experience
you're lucky if it's an outlier machine
you go in and you try and find out
what's wrong with that machine but
that's if you're lucky
can you speak to some of the techniques
yeah sure um so yeah these these are
really thorny problems and I think one
thing we do is you build an ad system
that's
just printing money and then you can
hire a lot of people to work on it I
mean I think that's what Google did but
if barring that I think another thing
you can do and actually that talk I was
referring to this Jeff Dean talk goes
into a lot of the specific techniques
that that that you know that they've
used at Google to get around this issue
when it when it's I mean obviously if
someone's doing something stupid you fix
it I mean that's that but that's not the
interesting one typically what you end
up doing is you will if you can't work
around it otherwise you'll do something
where you send the request to multiple
so instead of just having these
different shards you might have two
clones that actually have the same data
you send it to both and you accept the
fact that you're using us two resources
and then cancel the one that doesn't
come back first and and it's incredibly
expensive and it's incredibly painful
but it works great because you you know
you're you're doing you're like doing a
great deal to reduce the chance that
both of these clones are going to run
into that problem so that's like one of
the techniques they use
yeah I think that's true especially when
you try to be careful about using your
resources I mean the other thing you can
do and this is sort of obvious is just
to reduce interference and move things
off of shared systems and and create a
more controlled environment but that's
pretty painful and really expensive but
that's something that a lot of projects
would do with with their highest value
systems they would just basically over
provision the system which is depressing
but they would do it yeah
yeah the question was if you're sampling
and logging one out of a thousand
requests how does it actually end up
somewhere where you can do something
with it is that fair at paraphrase so
well was dapper after that there was
additional sampling one tenth of those
requests would get would get centralized
into BigTable which is sort of like
Cassandra just like a big distributed
key-value store and so you could run
mapreduces and things like that over
that data and do really detailed
aggregate analysis but most they did to
State on disk and we had a system that
we had a daemon that was actually yeah
it was the scariest thing ever did at
Google for sure is running at a man that
ran is root and round every machine at
Google and and that's that's what this
was so it would it just it has really
really strict resource restrictions that
it imposes on itself and it sits there
and opens support to the world and
basically serves up this log data and
just anytime you ask for a request you
give it a time range that little binary
search the logs to find that range look
for the request you're asking for and
return it and that happens Interactive
speed so you could just you could just
you know basically you could you could
re was sort of resuscitate the trace
just by visiting all the actual machines
involved as long as he got there within
about a week after a week the data would
typically get reclaimed as log rotation
took place but that that was the that
was actually commonly how it was done so
you just build a process to serve it if
I were to do it again I wouldn't do it
that way when we built it Google
Google's network wasn't as good as it is
now and I think that networks in general
I've gotten so much faster of it last
five years or so it probably makes more
sense just to log the separate the
network to some central place initially
and skip this additional complexity of
having the data distributed across your
entire fleet of machines but that's how
we did it at the time
so you talked about a case like the one
up screen right now where you can you
can basically decompose the problem to
find the offending process or shark are
there any situations where it's not this
obvious and where the interactions
between unfortunately yes yeah I think
that there are a lot of situations where
it's not this obvious I mean the
question was are there's this this is a
pretty brain-dead example like anyone
can look at this and if you understand
what it's saying you can understand what
the problem is and the question is are
there things that are a lot more subtle
that that would be responsible are you
saying are there things that are more
subtle that explain this behavior then
like a GC hookup are you saying there
are things that where it doesn't have
this weird shape to it it just takes too
long in general yeah I mean definitely
I've seen that happen the types of let
me think if I can take a good example I
mean there have been situations where
it's often that you depend on some sort
of back-end that wasn't provisioned
correctly and you spin up a system that
has you know tens of thousands of
processes in it and this dependency
which is fine when you're testing at a
smaller scale becomes a serious problem
and then everything kind of grinds to a
halt and I feel like that pattern is
actually responsible for more of
Google's like user-visible outages and
most things I can think of it's it's a
difficult one to catch and staging and
and it's a difficult one to recover from
quickly in production as well so that's
one type of situation and often times
it's like a hot shard like if it's a big
table or something like that where you
have some big distributed store and all
these different pieces are
simultaneously doing their part of the
part of the job and then you know maybe
this one pieces has some picture in it
that ends up becoming a viral internet
you know success and you have too much
attention being given to it if you
haven't built good caching
infrastructure on top of that you can
end up with just a hot spot and those
things are notoriously
difficult to predict in and to fix as
well
yeah so the question is if I'm so eager
to trace go programs what am I actually
what information do I want to get out of
it is that basically the main thing I
want by far in a distributed system it's
just our PCs I just want to know when
the request came in when it went out and
when it came back and when you returned
to your parent in the tree that's the
main thing I want to know by far and I
also would like to know how much of that
time is spent over the network and how
much of at the time and an outstanding
our PC was spent actually in a server
because something like this I didn't
want to draw in here but in the
implementation at Google each one of
these bars well we'll have a breakdown
of how much the time was Network time on
the client-side how much was Network
time on the way back and how much was
actual processing time and so you can
discover that you know these services
aren't located close enough the
dependency that latency dependency is
such they need to be physically closer
so that those those network latencies
get get turned down so the RPC
information is the most important thing
probably by an you know an order of
magnitude and then second to that I
think it's really important just to kind
of log basic features of the request
because you end up with an outlier you
want to understand why is this an
outlier like what is it about this
request is so expensive and so often
logging that type of stuff
just i almost treat the RPC is just as
the function calls in the distributed
system so the type of stuff you would
want to log at the top of the function
is the type of stuff I'd want to see for
each RPC that goes to the system
yeah can you speak up and sorry
that's a really good question so the
question is do you to see is the system
clock when you're doing these sorts of
timing diagrams or what well you should
definitely run NTP that helps a lot and
it'll kind of get you within a few
milliseconds of reality I think for most
systems right now that's enough to to
get you where you need to be if you need
to have like you know sub millisecond
fidelity on these things then I think
you need to use a different system than
the one that I built but but spanner is
they published this paper if your two
ago and remember that has a really
interesting distributed clock section to
it and I think you could do something
like that and and have more fidelity
about the specific sequencing of events
which is almost more important than what
the actual times were but it would
probably be pretty expensive as well but
yeah I think NTP gets you most of the
way I love NTP
[Applause]